[Musique]
Argenton-sur-Creuse est une petite ville
de l'Indre traversée par la Creuse
l'artiste bolivien roré Carrasco il y a
trouvé son inspiration il a fait donc à
l'église du village de sa puissance
artistique à travers des peintures
fascinantes son fils Tupac Nathan pour
tous nous expliquer
c'est par là suivez la flèche ou suivez
Le
[Musique]
Paloma
ortema
le Tupac gras
alors déjà pour commencer tu t'appelles
vraiment
tupacco l'artiste
j'ai essayé je te suis fais-moi
découvrir un peu le parcours les oeuvres
de ton papa donc là ici on a le tableau
le plus ancien qu'on est qui est une
nature morte en fait tirait des de ce
que vous pouvez travailler sa mère qui
l'a réalisé à l'âge de 9 ans il faisait
des peintures comme ça à l'âge de 9 ans
c'est ce qui faisait
un très comme ça un œil au milieu un nez
mal fait
donc voilà l'atelier de peinture c'est
là où il travaillait plus jeune il avait
en fait des offres qui étaient beaucoup
plus engagées où il dénonçait en fait
souvent l'église et le traitement
comment était considérés les Indiens et
bien alors après au fur et à mesure de
ces rencontres etc il a changé pour eu
la peinture c'est une recherche
permanente de nous une expression et
donc du coup on va avoir des tableaux
tiens comme celui-ci il va représenter
en fait les lignes cosmiques qui nous
traversent de toutes parties de
retransmettre au niveau de ses peintures
qui arrive de tous les côtés donc avant
de partir à l'église et je vais te
montrer un portrait de Picasso il a pris
la pose pour
Carrasco j'étais né
à chaque fois
[Musique]
justement ce qui concerne l'église il y
a des membres de votre famille qui a
écrit un livre dont c'est ma soeur oclo
qui a coécrit un livre effectivement
pour aider à comprendre le message qui
est caché dans ses peintures elle est
dans l'église elle nous attend au fond
la famille presque au complet parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de frères et soeurs
quand même hein
alors dans la famille la spécialiste de
l'Église c'est toi Carrasco est parti et
il nous a dit j'aimerais que cette
oeuvre vive puisque je l'ai mise dans la
vie il fallait apprendre qu'est-ce qu'il
a voulu dire pour pouvoir retransmettre
ce message si Dieu est amour alors c'est
la vie et donc pour Carrasco et ben il
faut aimer la vie où il faut aimer Dieu
pour pouvoir la vivre il faut savoir que
Carrasco avait un bagage culturel au
niveau des religions très étoffées mais
il y avait aussi sa vision de la
cosmogonie amérindienne la culture
cosmogonique c'est donc la culture un
peu astronomique des Incas en fait les
en Amérique latine on nous dit toujours
vous là-bas dans les pays développés
vous commettez une erreur parce que vous
avez un peu d'argent et que vous achetez
un lopin vous dites c'est à moi les
Indiens dit c'est entièrement faux
puisque c'est nous les hommes qui
appartenant à la pachamam à la Terre
Mère et si on appartient à la Pachamama
on va appartenir à l'univers dans la
première travée et bien c'est un hommage
à la féminité pour Carrasco l'élément
sacré de la vie c'est l'élément féminin
puisque c'est l'élément qui donne la vie
merci au Clos merci Tupac et juste pour
le délice des prénoms il s'appelle
comment vos frères et soeurs
merci les Carrasco et bravo pour ce que
vous faites vous respectez sa mémoire
bravo j'espère qu'il y aura quand même
un footballeur professionnel dans la
famille parce que le nom carrastru
Carrasco Carrasco Carrasco
[Applaudissements]